- We're to let a and
b be rational numbers,
and let b be non-zero, they
have to say let b be non-zero
because we're about to divide by b.
Is a over b rational or irrational?
Well let's think about it,
they're both rational numbers
so that means that a, since
it's rational, can be expressed
as the ratio of two integers,
so I can write a is equal to m
over n, and same thing about
b, I could write b as being
equal to p over q, where
where m, n, p,
and q are integers,
are integers, by definition of what a
rational number is, they're
telling us these numbers
are rational so I can express
them as these types of ratios.
So what is a over b going to be?
a over b is going to be
m over n over p over q
which is equal to m over n,
if I divide by a fraction,
it's the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal.
q over p, let me write that a little bit,
q over p which is equal to
mq over np.
Well mq is going to be an
integer, if the product of
two integers is going to be
an integer, and np is going
to be another integer, the
product of two integers
is an integer, so I've just shown that
a over b can be
expressed as the ratio of
two integers, so a over b
is for sure, in fact I've just
proven it to you, a over b
is for sure going to be rational.
Let's do a few more of
these, this is interesting.
All right, so now we're saying let a and b
be irrational numbers.
Is a over b, let a and
b be irrational numbers.
Is a over b rational or irrational?
And, like always, pause
the video and try to think
this through, and you
might want do some examples
of some irrational numbers
and see if you can get,
when you divide them, you can get rational
or irrational numbers.
Well, let's just imagine
a world where, let's say,
that a is equal to, I dunno,
two square roots of two,
and b is equal to the square root of two.
Well, in that world, a
over b, a over b would be
two square roots of two
over the square root of two
which would be two, which is
very much a rational number,
I can express that as a ratio
of integers, I can write that
as two over one, there's actually
an infinite number of ways
I can express that as a
ratio of two integers.
So, in this case, I was able
to get a over b to be rational,
based on a and b being irrational.
But, what if, what if instead of,
what if a was equal to
the square root of two
and b is equal to the square root
of, let's say, b is equal
to the square root of seven.
Well, then a over b would
be equal to the square root
of two over the square root
of seven, which is still
going to be irrational, I
mean another way to think
about it, and I'm not proving
it here, but you could
think about it, this is
going to be the square root
of two sevens, so we
have something that's not
a perfect square under the
radical, so we're going
to end up with an irrational number.
So, we can show one example where a over b
is rational and we showed one example
where it is irrational,
so it can be either way.
Let's do a few more of these.
All right, let a be a
non-zero rational number.
Is a times the square root of
eight rational or irrational?
Well, the key here is, if you
multiply an irrational number
and why is this an irrational number?
It has a perfect square
in it, but it's not
a perfect square in and of itself.
The square root of eight is,
the square root of eight is
equal to the square
root of four times two,
which is equal to the
square root of four times
the square root of two, which is equal
to two square roots of two.
And, this is kind of
getting to the punchline
of this problem, but if I
multiply a rational times
an irrational, I am going
to get an irrational.
So the square root of
eight is an irrational,
and if I multiply that
times a rational number,
I'm still going to get
an irrational number.
So this is going to be,
for sure, irrational.
Let's do one more of these.
So we're to let a be an irrational number.
Is negative 24 plus a
rational or irrational?
And I won't give a formal
proof here, but to give you
more of an intuitive feel,
it's nice to just try out
some numbers, and I encourage
you to pause the video
and try to think through it yourself.
Let's just imagine some values,
imagine if a is irrational,
a is irrational, so what
if a was equal to negative
pi, which is approximately
equal to negative three point
one four one five nine and it keeps going
on and on forever, never repeating.
Well, then we would have
negative 24 plus a
would be equal to negative 24 minus pi,
which would be approximately negative 27
point one for one five
nine, the decimal expansion,
everything to the right of
the decimal, is going to be
the exact same thing as pi.
So this looks like, at least
for this example, is going
to be irrational, and let's
see, if a was square root of two
negative 24 plus the square root of two,
well, once again, I'm
not doing a proof here,
but intuitively, this is
going to be a decimal,
it's going to have a decimal expansion
that's going to go on
forever and never repeat,
and so this would just
change what's to the left
of the decimal, but not
really change what's,
well it would change what's
to the right of the decimal
because this is negative,
but it's still going to go on
forever and never repeat,
and if, in fact, this was
if this was this way, then
to the right of the decimal,
you would have the same thing
as the square root of two
to the left of the decimal,
you would just have
a different value, you
would have negative 25 point
whatever whatever whatever,
and so this is, when you add
a rational number to an
irrational number, we've proven
in other videos, a
rational plus an irrational
is going to be irrational, irrational.
If you want that proof,
we have other videos
within this tutorial.